T
YOU RESIGN WHEN YOU DISAGREED
WITH JOE BIDEN?
REPUBLICANS ARE ALSO MAD AT
GENERAL MILLEY BECAUSE HE IS
QUOTED OR AT LEAST HIS VIEWS ARE
REPRESENTED IN SEVERAL OF THESE
BOOKS ABOUT THE FINAL DAYS OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, AND
IT'S CLEARMAN MILLEY WAS WORRIED
ABOUT THE STABILITY AND WHAT
POTENTIAL DECISIONS MIGHT BE
MADE.
MARSHA BLACKBURN REPUBLICAN OF
TENNESSEE DECIDED TO PUT IT
RIGHT OUT THERE.
ASKED A COUPLE OTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT SOME OF THE EPISODES AND
SHE DECIDED STRAIGHT OUT
ESSENTIALLY TO FIND OUT HOW MUCH
DID YOU COOPERATE.
>> GENERAL MILLEY, YES OR NO TO
THIS.
DID YOU TALK TO BOB WOODWARD OR
ROBERT COSTA FOR THEIR BOOK
"PERIL.
?
>>" WOODWARD YES AND COSTA NO.
>> DID YOU TALK TO THE AUTHORS
OF THE BOOK "CAN I FIX IT?
>> YES.
>> DID YOU TALK TO MICHAEL
BENDER FOR HIS BOOK "AS FRANKLY
WE DID WIN THIS ELECTION, THE
INSIDE STORY OF HOW TRUMP LOST?"
YES OR NO.
>> YES.
>> AND WERE YOU ACCURATELY
REPRESENTED IN THESE BOOKS?
>> I HAVEN'T READ ANY OF THE
BOOKS.
>> A LITTLE BIT OF COMEDY AT THE
END THERE, BUT WE SHOULD BE
TEXTING OUR SOURCES RIGHT NOW
MAKE SURE THEY DON'T GET INVITED
TO HEARINGS UNDER OATH IF THEY
ARE GOING TO ASK THE QUESTIONS
UP THERE.
>> AND POTENTIALLY WE KNOW WHO
TO CALL IF WE DECIDE TO WRITE A
BOOK AS WELL.
JOHN.
HE DID SUGGEST HE DID TALK TO
ALMOST ALL OF THE AUTHORS, AND
WHILE HE HASN'T READ THE BOOKS
HE CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGED HE'S
SEEN THE MEDIA COVERAGE, ISN'T
EXACTLY DISPUTING ALL OF WHAT
WAS SAID THOUGH YOU RAISED SOME
THINGS THAT HE DID SAY TO NANCY
PELOSI OR DIDN'T, BUT THE POINT
BEING THAT THERE WAS A PRIMARY
SOURCE.
HE'S JUST ADMITTED IT WAS HIM.
>> HE DID DISPUTE THOUGH THAT HE
WAS ACCURATELY DESCRIBED.
I'M SORRY.
IN THE VERY TOP HE DEVOTED A
VERY SIZABLE CHUNK OF HIS
PRESUMED REMARKS AND OPENING
STATEMENTS SAYING NO, AT NO
POINT WAS I TRYING TO HEM IN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND AT NO POINT WAS I MAKING
SECRET CALLS TO THE -- THAT'S
ALL.
>> I DIDN'T MEAN TO SAY TO
PELOSI THAT I BELIEVED THAT.
>> HE DIDN'T READ THE BOOKS.
HE CLEARLY CLOSELY READ THE
MEDIA ACOUNTS AND THE MEDIA
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE BOOKS
TO.
YOUR POINT WHAT HE SAID WAS I'M
NOT QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> BUT IT GOES BACK TO THE
THREAT OF THE CIVILIAN CONTROL
OF THE MILITARY.
WHAT WAS AMAZING ABOUT SOME OF
THESE THE BOOKS IS THEY WERE
CLEARLY SUGGESTING THAT WE WAS
STEPPING OUTSIDE THE BOUND OF
THE CONSTITUTIONAL DIVIDE AND HE
TOOK PAINS, NO, NO, NO, WE
BELIEVE IN CIVILIAN CONTROL OF
THE MILITARY.
>> IT'S OBVIOUS HE HAD SPOKEN TO
SOME OF THE AUTHORS.
IF YOU READ THE BOOKS, A TWO-WAY
CONVERSATION THAT HE HAD WITH
SOMEONE SO IT'S PRETTY CLEAR HE
PARTICIPATED.
I DO THINK IT'S NOTABLE THAT HE
SAID THAT.
I THINK THE LARGER POINT IS THAT
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS
OF STAFF FELT THE NEED TO SIT
DOWN WITH THESE HIGHLY RESPECTED
AUTHORS, TALK TO THEM ABOUT HIS
EXPERIENCES IN THIS ROLE BEING
HAND PICKED BY TRUMP, SOMEONE
WHO, OF COURSE, HAS NOW TURNED
ON HIM AND VIEWS HIM QUITE
DIFFERENTLY, BUT I DO THINK IT
SPEAKS TO THE LEVEL OF GRAVITY
IN THIS SITUATION REGARDLESS OF
WHAT YOU FEEL ABOUT MILLEY OF
WHAT THEY WERE FACE WHEN TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT.
>> YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
IF THERE WAS KIND OF A CAMERA ON
US WHILE WE WERE WATCHING THAT
IT WAS A MOMENT TO WATCH THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS BE
ASKED WHETHER YOU TALKED TO ALL
OF THESE AUTHORS, BOOM, BOOM,
BOOM.
YES, ONE-WORD ANSWER AFFIRMING
IT.
IT WAS DEFINITELY A MOMENT.
IT WAS -- IT WAS AFFIRMING WHAT
WAS PRETTY OBVIOUS.
I GUESS HE DIDN'T HAVE A CHOICE.
HE WAS ASKED UPPED OATH.
>> ALSO JUST SO RARE.
YOU DON'T HAVE -- I HOPE YOU
DON'T HAVE 20-YEAR WARS WHERE
THIS COMES UP, BUT JUST TO SEE
AMERICA'S TOP GENERAL AS
ESSENTIALLY THE STAR WITNESS,
EVEN THOUGH THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY WAS HERE AND SOME OF
THE OTHER COMBATANT COMMANDERS
WERE THERE, FOR MILLEY TO BE
THERE AND TO THE POINT A MOMENT
AGO WE TALKED ABOUT IT SO LET'S
JUST LISTEN.
IN THE BOOK, IN "THE PERIL" BOOK
NANCY PELOSI SAID SHE WAS HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION IS THE
PRESIDENT GOING TO LAUNCH A
MILITARY ATTACK.
YOU KNOW HE'S CRAZY.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID AND NANCY
PELOSI SAID HE AGREED WITH HER.
HE SAYS --
>> SHE WAS CONCERNED AND MADE
VERY OR MADE VARIOUS PERSONAL
REFERENCES CHARACTERIZING THE
PRESIDENT.
I EXPLAINED TO HER THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS THE SOLE NUCLEAR
LAUNCH AUTHORITY AND HE DOESN'T
LAUNCH THEM ALONE AND THAT I AM
NOT QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> YOU ARE ON THE PROGRAM AND
MAKING THIS POINT WHEN THE BOOK
CAME OUT THAT SOUNDS OF THAT
SOUNDS LIKE, WHOA, WHAT WAS
MILLEY DOING, BUT THE WAY HE
DESCRIBES IT ANYWAY IS THAT, NO,
ACTUALLY, WE HAVE PROCEDURES AND
HE WAS AS A VETERAN OF THE
SYSTEM USING THE SYSTEM TO HIS
ADVANTAGE.
>> HE'S PART OF THE CHAIN OF
COMMUNICATION, NOT THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND WHICH IS HOW HE PHRASED
IT IN HIS STATEMENTS TODAY AND
THE POINT THAT HE DESCRIBES
MAKING TO NANCY PELOSI IS THERE
WAS NOT GOING TO BE AN ILLEGAL
OR ACCIDENTAL LAUNCH WHICH IS
PRETTY IMPORTANT.
UP OTHER THING THAT MILLEY SAID
THAT I THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING
AND SENATOR JOE MANCHIN POINTED
TO IT AS WELL.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
THIS WAR WASN'T LOST IN THE LAST
MONTH OR LAST YEAR.
>> RIGHT.
>> JOE MANCHIN COMING OUT AND
SAYING HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT
YOU GUYS WERE CAUGHT BY
SURPRISE?
EVERY TIME WE'VE HAD AN ANALYSIS
OF THIS CONFLICT, PEOPLE HAVE
COME BACK AND SAID THEY CAN'T
STAND ON THEIR OWN.
THEY CAN'T FIGHT WITHOUT
AMERICAN SUPPORT.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS A CRISIS OF
LGTSSY.
THERE'S RAMPANT CORRUPTION BY,
BY THE WAY, THE U.S. FIELD.
THAT WAS A GOOD MOMENT TOO AND I
THINK IT WAS MILLEY WHO SAID,
YEAH, WELL, RIGHT THIS.
WHAT IS LOST OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST TWO DECADE.
>> RIGHT.
>> ALSO HIM SAYING THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY AGREE WITH WHAT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT SAID ABOUT HOW
MANY AMERICANS ARE LEFT THERE,
THAT THEY DON'T REALLY HAVE A
GOOD ACCOUNTING OF THAT, MANCHIN
RAISING HOW MUCH EQUIPMENT IS
THERE.
THOSE ARE BIG QUESTIONS THAT ARE
NOT GOING AWAY.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT BECAUSE
YOU HEARD FRUSTRATION EVEN FROM
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THE PENTAGON
KEEPS SAYING ASK THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT SAYS ASK THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT AND SENATOR KAINE
SAID GET YOUR ACT TOGETHER.
>> AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF AFGHANISTAN IS RIGHT NOW NOR
DO THEY KNOW HOW MUCH U.S.
AMERICAN DOLLARS HE HAS WITH
HIM.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> GOING BACK TO TIM KAINE, YOUR
POINT, NOT JUST REPUBLICANS,
IT'S DEMOCRATS AND ONE POINT
THAT TIM KAINE HAD RAISED, IF
YOU CAN'T GET PEOPLE TO TAKE THE
VACCINE IN AMERICA, YOU CAN'T
GET PEOPLE TO BELIEVE NAT
ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN, WHY DID
YOU THINK THAT YOU WERE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE AFGHANS TO BE
ABLE TO FIGHT FOR THEMSELVES,
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT --
>> AND TO ACCEPT DEMOCRATIC
NORMS, TO ACCEPT THAT WOMEN
SHOULD BE EDUCATED, TO ACCEPT A
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
A GREAT POINT.
HOW DO YOU CHANGE A NATION WHEN
YOU HAVE A HARD TIME PERSUADING
YOUR OWN AND THE WHITE HOUSE
WATCH EDS POINTS LIKE THIS
BECAUSE EVEN THE DEMOCRATS WERE
MAD ABOUT HOW IT HAPPENED, EVEN
DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORT IT'S TIME
TO END THE WAR IN AFGHANISTAN,
TIME TO LEAVE, HAD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE MESSY WITHDRAWAL.
THE WHITE HOUSE YOU'RE SENDING A
THANK YOU NOTE TO ELIZABETH
WARREN WHO WENT OUT OF HER WAY
TO COME TO THE PRESIDENT'S
DEFENCE.
>> DID PRESIDENT BIDEN TOM YOUR
ADVICE ON EXECUTED ON THE
EVACUATION PLAN?
>> HE DID.
>> DID PRESIDENT BIDEN GIVE YOU
ALL THE RESOURCES THAT YOU
NEEDED?
>> FROM MY VIEW HE DID.
>> DID PRESIDENT BIDEN IGNORE
YOUR ADVICE ON THE EVACUATION AT
ANY POINT?
>> NO, SENATOR, HE DID NOT.
>> THE DID HE REFUSE ANY
REQUESTS FOR ANYTHING THAT YOU
NOTED OR ASKED FOR?
>> NO.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED
ISSUE, AND THERE WILL BE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT YOU SAW THERE THOUGH IS A
FELLOW DEMOCRAT WHO UNDERSTANDS
THIS IS PART OF THE TOLL ON THE
PRESIDENT'S POLL NUMBERS, THE
RISING COVID CASES, THE MESSY
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN.
THAT'S A DEMOCRAT TRYING TO COME
TO THE PRESIDENT'S ASSIST.
>> NEVER MIND THAT IT WAS FOR
CONTEXT AFTER THE BARN DOOR
CLOSED.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT AND
EVERYBODY SAW WHAT WAS GOING ON
THERE, OF COURSE HE'S GOING SAY
YES TO EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING
THE MILITARY WANTS TO TRY TO
CALM THE CHAOS AND EVACUATE
PEOPLE.
THE QUESTIONS, THE LARGER
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS WE GOT
TODAY WERE WHAT ABOUT BEFORE THE
DECISION TO WITHDRAW AND WHY NOT
HEED THE MILITARY RECOMMENDATION
TO LEAVE SOME TROOPS THERE?
>> AND I THINK RAISES ONE OTHER
BIG QUESTION IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT FELT REPEATEDLY HE
FELT BOUND BY THIS AGREEMENT
THAT TRUMP STRUCK WITH THE
TALIBAN AND THAT'S WHY HE HAD TO
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE TIMELINE
AND THAT'S SOMETHING HE SAID
REPEATEDLY.
THEY SAID THE TALIBAN ONLY
HONORED ONE PART THAT HAVE SO
ESSENTIALLY IT WAS DEFUNCT AND
THEY WEREN'T ACTUALLY FOLLOWING
WHAT IT SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
>> GENERAL MILLEY WAS VE